you know who else is running Brene brown
she's running all over the country her
TED talk on the power of vulnerability
is one of the most popular ever with
more than 39 million views she discusses
why we struggle with being vulnerable
miss Brown is a New York Times
bestselling author thank you very much
with two decades of experience
researching courage shame and empathy
she hopes to spread her message about
embracing our vulnerabilities in her new
Netflix special
Brene brown the call to courage the
opposite of belonging from the research
is fitting in that's the opposite of a
lot fitting in is assessing and
acclimating here's what I should say B
here's what I shouldn't say here's what
I should avoid talking about here's what
I should dress like look like that's
fitting in belonging is belonging to
yourself first speaking your truth
telling your story and never betraying
yourself for other people
true belonging doesn't require you to
change who you are it requires you to be
who you are and that's vulnerable Rene
Brown joins us first on CBS this morning
to discuss we were talking about you in
the makeup room Nora and I and everybody
else who walked in said hey you should
here zone see what you miss in the
makeup room while we're getting our hair
did I know well my hair takes we watch
we watch it we love we love because you
said vulnerability is not a weakness and
I should show it
I don't know anybody Brene that wants
anybody to know they're feeling
vulnerable or that it's an asset to
whatever it's going on in your life and
you say what thank you there's a lot of
Mythology about vulnerability and the
big one is that it's weakness yeah and
so from the data the definition of
vulnerability is uncertainty risk and
emotional exposure and I had this like
life-changing career changing moment
staying in front of special forces US
military and I asked a question can
anyone in this room give me an example
of courage in your life or in someone
else's life that didn't require
uncertainty risk and emotional exposure
and there was just silence until finally
one guy stood up and said three tours
there's no courage without vulnerability
no and we just we don't underst
and that vulnerability is the center of
hard emotions the stuff that we don't
want to feel somewhat especially at work
but it's also the birthplace of trust
love belonging you have to have
vulnerability to be brave give us an
example because in your dock you you
tik-tok a lot of examples of
vulnerability yeah like I mean when we
asked people we've asked thousands of
people what does vulnerability you hear
everything from saying I love you first
the first date after my divorce trying
to get pregnant after my second
miscarriage you know getting fired
firing someone starting my own business
as a parent the one that just killed me
I remember seeing across from this
research participant and she said for me
vulnerability is sending my son to
orchestra practice today
I mean tryouts today knowing how bad he
wants to make first chair and knowing he
probably won't make the orchestra at all
like there is no courage without being
all in like if you can do something and
not feel vulnerable it's probably not
that brave I think one of the hardest
things and being vulnerable which then
leads to creativity which then leads to
success as you say the hardest part in
taking that first step is fear of
failure fear of the critics and I want
to play part of this from your special
because I think it really speaks to why
many people never take that first step
listen there are millions of cheap seats
in the world today filled with people
who will never want step foot in that
arena they will never once put
themselves out there but they will make
it a full-time job to hurl criticism and
judgment and really hateful things
toward us and we have got to get out of
the habit of catching them and
dissecting and holding them close to our
hearts we got to let them drop on the
floor don't grab that hurtful stuff from
the cheap seats and pull it close don't
pull it anywhere near your heart easier
said than done oh god you say you don't
take criticism and feedback from people
who are not being brave with their lives
you know we can't and here's the thing
here's what I've discovered if you sum
up all the research over 20 years
everyone wants to be brave no one wants
to be vulnerable yeah and that is the
rub you know that is what we all
reconcile
our entire adult lives is how do I be
brave with my life with my work with my
partner with my kids and stay safe and
armored at the same time and the answer
is you don't and the cheap seats are
like twenty two years of doing this work
I've never seen the cheap seats like
they are today yeah twitter is fizzies I
call them hey is there no part of
bravery that doesn't contain the
sublimation of vulnerability because
when you talk about three tours when you
talk about the people who are a champion
for their bravery some component of it
often is they were fearful vulnerable
they sublimated that and succeeded I
mean that is that is there no part of
bravery that contains basically putting
away your vulnerability I think it
depends on how you define it but if you
define vulnerability as uncertainty and
risk and emotional exposure like we'd
asked probably 10,000 people that
question the week after I was with the
service people I went and I was doing
some work with the Seattle Seahawks and
asked them the same question and then
they were just shocked for a second they
were like no every day on the field is
vulnerable so I don't I think we can get
used to being vulnerable a little bit
and maybe in that way bravery becomes a
practice and feels less scary but I
think I know for myself every time I'm
being brave I feel scared sure and it's
a common you know performers talked
about right before they go onstage to a
part they've done a million times they
feel like they're about to die yeah so
it's there I guess the question is for
for some people if they turn inward to
their vulnerability they can get stuck
in it make sure turn round around so
what is the distinction between
obsessing over your vulnerability and
recognizing it by being able to or leap
it in order to to be successful you know
what I think it is it's a learned
practice of discomfort I have learned
how to manage my discomfort physically
physically the physiology of
vulnerability is is real right that it's
a side car to success you know an
impediment to it I had a question last
night that someone asked me in an
audience and she was kind of shaking and
crying and she said I've got a book
coming out I'm scared to death I don't
know what to do and this is how I feel
and I said congratulations
this is what courage looks like yeah you
said vulnerability is not about winning
or losing it's the courage to show up
when you don't know the outcome but this
is one of my favorite things you said by
choosing to be brave you're going to get
your paycheck you're going to fail
you're going to know heartbreak why
would we make that choice if you get
there but heartbreak and it's a good
question but here's the problem
hard things are born of vulnerability
yeah heartbreak fear this grief
disappointment but love joy belonging
intimacy Trust created you know creating
innovation are also born so when we
armored up to block the hearts the hard
stuff that Armour keeps all of the
experiences that bring meaning to our
lives away as well I may be quoting you
back to yourself but not taking a risk
is a risk itself oh yeah and it can you
imagine I mean this is like how in the
special getting to the end of our lives
and having to ask what if I would have
shown up yeah what if I would have said
yes to me that's more terrifying than
putting myself out there that's why they
say yes yes yes Renee I after watching
it I texted so many people I texted
couples who are friends of mine who I
know are watching tonight and watch this
with your husband your house I texted so
many people so it's worth just Netflix
and you guys did a great job
it's very that's great it Samantha bee
when she walked in the green room and
the two of them saw each other they go I
just watch your special it's so good
there's something have to be I love it
when girls come together and say yeah
you're good yeah it was a very nice man
sharing you want to you
Renee brown thank you you can watch
grenade Brown it's called the curve the
call to courage rather on Netflix you
can get it right now after CBS this
morning